Nói kuy ra em, nó cứu laetet mại, dùng đảy loổi với khuy, thấy đi quý,
mang nghe chính chị quý, đó đi, nó mô kể chính chị quý mới sau khi dùng đảy tinh.
Đầu từ thì chúng ta cũng phải theo dõi hiệu sốt của khuy.
Nói kuy ra em, nó cứu mua nhà mà mỗi năm là phải tán triệu mối tân chăm.
Mỗi năm tán chăm, mỗi năm tán chăm, mỗi năm tán chăm.
Mời gây quý, nó cứu laetet mại, dùng đảy loổi với khuy, thấy đi quý,
mang nghe chính chị quý, đó đi, nó mô kể chính chị quý mới sau khi dùng đảy tinh.
Thế còn anh không ngủ hộ, cái việc là hôm nay mô khuy này,
sau lại bạn đi và mô khuy khác,
có nhiều mũ của anh là chúng ta sẽ phải hiệu chính mình.
Hều phải sọng tiền của mình,
hều phải...
Tất em, một kiểu được tư của mình, hều phải hồ sơ, hồ mình,
sau đó chúng ta hiểu cái quyết, nhưng hình là đủ tư.
Và sau khi đủ tư rồi thì thì cứ ăn tâm theo đuổi,
cái một kiểu của chúng ta và năm để tâm tâm.
Không cần phải xí nghĩ và nhớ.